hey guys I'm Alanna or Charizard and I
am here at supernova 2013 and sitting
next to me is the one at hourly fixing
Yoko Ono
thank God right so you play Edward Elric
my favorite characters I'm honored i
loved-ed to that little pipsqueak I
become my favorite oh really I mean I
played a lot of different roles but when
you play one character for that yeah and
it's a good character to do you know I
mean the one thing you play the same
very passionate times is there's about
the Bregman character but Edie is just
such a wonderful tragic hero
and so I resisted for a long time
but now I can't help it anymore think
there's Edie
and there's Tamaki right anyway sorry
but how do you sleep okay so for that
amount
well you know the truth is that a lot of
times we don't know what's coming
so we get in to this studio and we start
watching the scenes we start reading the
lines and
so one of the things that's cool about
that is that there is a a spontaneous
visceral reaction
as opposed to I know it's coming
practicing ever there's this holy moly
moment where oh my god please do it look
what he's saying and then you really
still kind of fresh
so if it's not spontaneous
how did you react to the
I love them both for different reasons
of course but I tell you what the ending
of brotherhood
after having done everything
and I can't it's so funny if somebody
asked me to do the last lines
he says substances
and they had it on their phone and I did
it
absolutely
didn't want to see that in
the last time
he says
makes basically proposals to remove and
that's the kind of thing you saw hopping
water time right you want everybody
wanted it to happen and finally looks at
or you know these all nervous he's like
a Google in exchange I'll give you half
my life don't give me it
you said you've been
how do you getting the voice acting
random you know truthfully it's very
different now
when I got into he that it was very
small
anime was this niche subculture
I was just encouraged to audition
at what point if you actually realize
such different voices
I don't think I mean about what I was
young I would always personally like my
friends
skin system but you know anime voice
acting I must be honest it's not about
changing there are a lot of characters
might sound very similar
but that's because the bill is to change
your voice the goal is to play the
character
honestly
you could pull lines from many different
characters always just one line and you
could bring the string them all together
and you'd be like oh yeah this has to
say but the characters say if you watch
it and then you watch poor girl there
for that oh my god
so I guess what I mean to say is the
goal and voice acting is to play the
character the example that I use all the
time is you can pick any movie after you
know and they've done tons of different
characters but they always sound the
same because they're not trying to
change your voice all the time they just
need to play you're trying to play a
character so did you do the acting
poncho
so very very did a lot of stage work and
theater they spawn camera work
building up to alternately getting a
chance to question my least-favorite
when there's a another video game a new
new Dragon Ball video game they'll
literally call me and start the
conversation I'm sorry he's back more
broadly I'm like oh but thank you so
much i LSU thank you so much thanks guys